[Música]
un vestido inspirado en el 'guernica' de
picasso un atuendo muy especial
compuesto de 12 kilos de chocolate es la
estrella de este salón que se inaugura
este jueves en parís nada fácil de
llevar ante una tentación tan grande me
encanta el chocolate me tengo que
contener para no comerla ni vestido pero
detrás de esta hermosa prenda hay una
realidad amarga de 100.000 millones de
euros de ingresos generados por la
industria chocolatera sólo el 2% llega a
los agricultores que cultivan los granos
de cacao la mayoría de ellos en áfrica
costa de marfil y ghana proveen cerca de
la mitad de esta producción hace dos
años decidieron cobrar un excedente
sobre cada tonelada de grano de cacao a
los exportadores una prima denominada el
diferencial de rendimiento destinada a
mejorar la remuneración de los
productores pero este año su importe ha
bajado en cerca de un 20% hasta 125
euros por kilo aproximadamente y aunque
los agricultores amenazaron con una
huelga dieron marcha atrás nos habría
encantado que hubiera sido más
hubiéramos querido que fuera un euro y
medio por kilo pero vimos como la
temporada pasada el precio se fijó en un
euro y medio y todos tuvimos problemas
sobre el terreno para vender
creo entonces que si el presidente de la
republica lo hizo es porque no tenía
elección a comienzos de octubre el
gobierno francés el sindicato de los
chocolateros y varias ong se
comprometieron a poner en lugar un plan
de acción de aquí a marzo para mejorar
la remuneración de los productores pero
también para luchar contra el trabajo
forzado de los niños en las plantaciones
y la deforestación un llamado también a
la responsabilidad del consumidor a la
hora de darse un goloso placer